the investigation is underway this
morning into the circumstances
surrounding a dramatic fishing video
posted to social media and we need to
warn you these pictures are very
disturbing this video appears to show a
group of man laughing while dragging a
captured shark behind a fast-moving
motorboat off the coast of Florida Jeff
Glor is here with outrage from both the
public and industry experts Jeff good
morning Gail good morning to you sport
fishing is big in Florida especially
sport fishing for sharks but what this
video appears to show is not fishing
it's abuse the video said to be captured
off the coast of Florida appears to show
a number of fishermen dragging a large
shark behind a powerboat the shark looks
to be pulled behind the boat with a rope
traveling at a high rate of speed while
the men inside the boat seem to be
enjoying it I guess they were followers
may be fans of mine on my account and
they just wanted to get my reaction
charter boat captain Mark oriano has
been sport fishing for 50 years he says
he posted the 10-second clip to
Instagram after one of the men sent him
the video
mark was angry and so were his followers
they tied the shark up by the tail
they let the fish drowned they dragged
him for hours they the shark with tor
pieces that's not a sportsman that's
just animal cruelty
the Florida Fish and Wildlife
Conservation Commission is investigating
but they say it's too early to conclude
any violations occurred this is clearly
abuse this is this is animal torture
there's professor Stephen Kajiura has
been studying shark biology for over 20
years so it can't breathe it would be
like dragging you underwater how long
would you survive if you were dragged
behind the boat underwater you wouldn't
survive very long they were happy to be
dragging that shark behind the boat and
basically torturing it and they didn't
seem to be bothered at all and I think
that's more disturbing than than
anything the biologists we spoke to says
he can't tell for sure what kind of
shark it is investigators also have to
figure out who was on the boat and
exactly where the video was taken before
moving forward I think that biologist
makes a really good point it's
disturbing that they didn't seem to care
and that they enjoyed being so cruel to
another creature well then it appeared
to watch tied up by a rope yeah how do
we bury time up right lord only knows
but they're wrong figure it out so many
levels Jeff alright Jeff thank you so
much